little people know i lost my granddad
and he was my father figure like he
raised me
you know with colby there's no
spectators and he's just crazy like now
you know he's in heaven and he's my
guardian angel and he's going to be
right there with me in tokyo
from the golden arches to going for the
gold quinisha berg started out like so
many
working at mcdonald's now she's off to
compete at the olympics in tokyo but
first she's talking to
us quinisha
girl congratulations this
is beyond major especially considering
your story how are you feeling
i'm just i feel blessed like i honestly
it haven't hit me yet then i'm an
olympian and i think um
this week when i leave and i'm in tokyo
it's gonna hit me
but honestly i'm just so just like i'm a
loss for worse i'm just so happy and
blessed to be in this position
and just so happy that my dreams became
reality right now it's just
i feel like i'm not gonna hide right now
yes you're experiencing
a feeling that a lot of people
unfortunately sometimes don't get to
experience you know
it your biggest possible dream coming
true
so talk to us about the moment when you
found out you qualified
on the track what were the initial
thoughts that went through your head
well honestly before i had this planned
reaction
that i would drop to the ground and i
would just you know just like put my
hands up and seriously coming down i'm
like
can't believe this that didn't happen
but um honestly after i realized i made
the team
it just felt like a relief and just like
a burden because it's like oh
i'm the olympian like i made the team
because you work hard all your life and
you know five years you know with cobit
so it's like we've been working five
years for this moment and with track and
field usa is the hardest team to make
so you can go in number one and not make
the team at all and like break a world
record and not make the usa team
so honestly knowing that once they gave
me my flowers
and the flag congratulations you're
olympian you go to the olympics i was
like
oh my gosh i'm an olympian so it just
felt like wow
all the hard work everything i've been
through these years it's finally paid
off and now i get to officially say i'm
an olympian
just hearing my story i have the truth
and then considering the fact that you
had an injury
a few months ago where you could barely
jog
and yeah you and you still made the team
even after going through that trial
what is what did that teach you oh my
gosh patience
i'm very impatient and when i tell you
my patience was tested and i honestly
i'm so thankful for the journey that
brought me to where i am now
because i've never really had a serious
injury during a season
so once i found like i had severe bone
bruising to my femur
and i had a tender strain in the back of
my leg and it's all on my jump leg i
take off with
it was just like very frustrating but
then i realized that
you know god did not bring me this far
just to leave me and so it was a test
and this year
my word was trust and that was honestly
was i was put
to the test instead i was like okay next
i gotta be careful with my words
right here because but it was honest
it was hard but i had a small circle
with my family and friends
but they killed me motivated and there
were times like i was frustrated and
i could tell like negative thoughts and
self-doubt was coming in but i was like
nope this is not gonna happen
it was a challenge but i'm just so glad
to give it to myself and i said i'm
gonna make this team
and i was just so ready and i just knew
that god put me through all those
challenges this entire
year for this one moment and i was so
ready
so it was stressful at the like the
process
but finally making the team it was worth
it
and now i'm just like i get to share my
story and i love that you're so open
about sharing it you're so open about
sharing your
faith which i love you talk about how
you manifested this
how you kept speaking into existence
that you were going to be an olympian
and now you're here
i'm going to be an olympian
i will make the 2021 olympics
okay i'm speaking of an olympia
i'm going to be in olympia i'm going
to the olympics i'm claiming it now
i'm going to be an olympian today is the
day
i told you i'm an olympian
i'm an olympian i told you the power of
the tongue
i realized my purpose is bigger than me
and myself and
so i feel like god has given this talent
and this is a bridge you know for others
to know
like my like this was a test and it's a
testimony now and it's just my purpose i
feel like i'm really fulfilling my
purpose
of sharing my story so i can inspire
others because everyone needs that
inspiration
could be because you think like oh
everything was great she made the team
but it was so much more like like
involved before like you see the flowers
and the flag in my hand
and i'm screaming i'm an olympian and on
those videos actually when i'm saying
i'm an olympian
literally people know like some of those
clips i only see my confidence it wasn't
that high at first i was like i hope
i'll become an olympian
it's everyone's dream to become olympian
i was like no no no you're going to be
olympian
and so each video my confidence just
kept growing and it's on the day of the
competition
but today's the day i'm going to be an
olympian and i just had this feeling
that i know it's going to happen because
i've been through too much
too much and i was like i'm not going to
lose i'm going to make this team
the only way i will not make this team
if i get away from my own success so
honestly when i say this year has just
been
and going back to 2019 little people
know i lost my granddad
and he was my father figure like he
raised me like he was basically my dad
and i lost him at the usa trials of 2019
we buried him thursday
i flew out friday and i competed
saturday and i missed the team by one
spot
for world championships of 2019 hey so
that is still another
like another queue like this beast just
came out i was like
i'm not missing another team like he's
my guardian angel
and i'm doing this for him and so
honestly starting that for 2019
built this cue that i prepared me for
2021 with the injury
so i was like this injury is not gonna
like define me
i lost someone important to me so if i
had to go and take an injury i would
take an injury because i went through
something worse than that
who's an olympian me and i just get
emotional sometimes
like yesterday i was like wow i'm really
packing for the olympics
and just to thank my grandparents you
know my granddad's like we're going to
go to the olympics
we can't wait to go and you know with
colby there's no spectators
and he's just crazy like now you know
he's in heaven and he's my guardian
angel and he's going to be right there
with me in tokyo
so i'm just so excited because they were
like they played a big part on my life
with where i am now for sure girl your
your whole perspective on that because
you know because of cobit and everything
people aren't going to be able to
be in the audience but your grandfather
is closer probably than he's ever
been to you yes at that moment wow you
honestly you're making me tear up just
thinking about it
because it's it's it just adds another
perspective to this whole
it's bigger than you think right because
your grandparents you know their prayers
all of that you know
results in you just going out here girl
and killing
it like that was my grammy
like after like i caught i was like hey
i made the olympic team
just like oh my gosh even though i was
like yes and then it's just like i had a
moment the hotels like
granted we did it and before my jump my
fifth jump
because i know i was not down from third
place to sixth place and we had two more
jumps left
and you know you see your dreams just
like falling like just getting further
away from you
and i was like no no no i'm not doing
this and so i went over and i just
prayed
and i just dropped to my knees i was
like god we're going to make this team
you did not bring me this far i have a
story to show everyone
and at that moment i just got on the
runway and i was like grenade let's do
this
and then brittany reese when i won and
she was like just running jump kill
i was like you're right and i just
cleared every pressure like the pressure
the stress that was on me i just cleared
and i was like
run and jump god is with you your
grenades there let's go
and i just went and did it and once i
jumped i was like yes i was like
that's the one and i just felt it i was
like that's the one i was like i'm going
to ruin this
and so i knew i had other jobs like
other people to jump but at that moment
we had another
round of jumps to do but at that moment
i was like no that's the one
i'm going it's so i just know he's just
watching he's so proud of me
and he's just so happy to see like a lot
of family friends that reach out to me
and they're like your granddaddy
i know he's screaming and just
celebrating you right now so i'm just
happy
yeah i think that's so important letting
people know that this
just isn't the end product so much went
behind it so much struggles
so many struggles so many lessons so
girls shout out to you for just being
open and honest about that back to your
family we know that they can't be there
your grandfather's going to be their
spirit how do they plan on supporting
you from afar what's the plan
so they're having a wash party for sure
they're attending watch party and you
know they're ready like in a day
they're probably a half of my family
don't know track and feel like that but
if they see my name up there
they're gonna scream so they're all like
having like going to watch watch party
they're all gonna celebrate
and they're just so excited now they're
trying to figure out the times with i
could be august first and third so
they're like okay
the tokyo time so what about american
time so they're like figuring that out
right now
but they're so excited and they're just
celebrating and at the end of the day
they're like
it doesn't matter what you do attract
like the games that you are winner
you're a winner right now
and that's what i'm going into the games
right now i feel like a winner already
because i faced so much
to be around now so now i'm really just
excited to see what i can do and now i
have another opportunity
to go out here and really live to my
full potential
because the olympic trials honestly
wasn't my best series at all in jumps
i mean my coach were like yeah you
didn't do the best and the fact still
made the team so we're so excited to see
what happened to olympic games
so they're excited they're getting ready
they're getting their shirts ready
and they're just like what is your
history comes tokyo so
they're so excited so i'm so excited for
them so they're keeping me like spirited
like
you got this cute so i'm sorry track and
field
a lot of eyes have been on the sport
lately because of stories like yours and
tara davis's
tell us why that is so important in your
opinion i definitely think tragophila
doesn't get a lot of attention
and a lot of people only talk about
gender olympic year some people do not
understand track and field
they don't know what's going on but
having a story and having athletes they
have a story you're engaging you're
investing those stories because you're
like wow i feel like
i'm a part of them like she shared me
her story so now i want to see how the
outcome is going to come
so it's just so great that we can share
our story we have this platform
that people are engaged right now this
olympic gear and they want to know and
not just feel like it's so
honest like it's great for us athletes
to be vulnerable and just share our
story like hey
it wasn't just like we became olympian
we woke up and we're olympian we faced
so much and the olympics come around
every four years and you have to be
honestly
perfect on that day you literally have
to and some people you don't be perfect
like you literally
have to be perfect on one track meet to
make the team to have that olympian
around your name for the rest of your
life so it's just so great that we're
able to use this platform
and be able to share our story because
you don't have to know a lot about track
and field but you know the athlete and
your story
you're going to be invested you're going
to learn and then this opportunity for
us to educate others
about track and field there's so many
wonderful things that's gonna happen for
usa
once you go to olympus like there's a
world record broken at the olympic
trials
a lot of people probably not even know
and it's just so exciting so many people
are engaged and just want to know and
want to know more about it and want to
know more about
the athletes in our story in the sport
so i think this is really great
for the entire like track and field
community for sure yeah
for sure for sure well mcdonald let's
talk about that because you did work
there before
a lot of celebrities are coming out with
their signature meals nowadays travis
scott was one
and there are a few others if you had a
signature mcdonald's meal what would it
be
okay it would definitely be a fry a
medium final sauce
and i would get a caramel sundae because
i like to get my fries in
and let's throw some oreos on the sun on
the sunday as well
and i will have a quarter pounder extra
bacon extra cheese
only mayo and pickles
and that's it it's funny because i used
to order that a lot
and so that's something that after the
trials i actually went straight to
mcdonald's
i was like ugh i need a fry i was like i
haven't had a fry in months so i was
like i need to fry now
so i think that'll be my signature meal
for sure yeah well
dripping fries and freaking ice cream i
have friends that do that and i still
don't understand
you have to try like dip the fry scoop
some ice cream and then dip it in the
carrot
and then try it you gotta try all
together and i promise
it's the best i'll love it